et si on imaginait l'école de demain
je me souviendrai toujours la première
fois que j'en ai discuté avec les ans on
allait surtout glisse-t-elle à la longue
liste des problèmes de l'éducation
oui enfin je vous parle des problèmes de
l'éducation mais au final on n'est pas
là pour ça abbassi si bastian des sites
pour le coup on est complet pour là pour
parler de ça justement en fait qu'il
faut quand même se rendre compte qu'on
est à l'aube d'un des plus grands
tournants quand même dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
et vous me direz rien que ça et oui rien
que ça en fait parce que y'a une chose
assez simple à comprendre
une grande révolution est en train
d'apparaître ça s'appelle l'intelligence
artificielle je suis certain que vous en
avez tous entendu parler
on voulait sûrement rabâcher d'ailleurs
mais cette intelligence artificielle
elle va détruire de l'emploi
c'est une certitude détruire de l'emploi
carrément d'ailleurs si l'on en croit la
destruction créatrice de notre chère
schumpeter et explique quelque chose
c'est justement ces emplois qui ont été
perdus par la robotisation vont être
remplacés par des emplois de service
donc au final on ne peut pas du tout
prédire les futures innovations qui vont
venir combler les pertes de
l'intelligence artificielle
alors si bien mon cher louis tu as très
bien aiguisé ton cours d'économie
sauf que non sauf que dans ça ne
marchera pas en fait pour une raison qui
est extrêmement simple c'est que il y a
elle va bouleverser beaucoup trop de
métier beaucoup trop de secteurs en même
temps fait donc ça ne marche pas je me
plais bien sur ce coup d'ailleurs il ya
quelque chose qu'il le prouve assez bien
c'est les personnels ainsi que le valais
des patrons de la silicon valley c'est
quand même le lieu on recueille toute
l'intelligence artificielle sur cette
planète
une bonne partie du moins il souhaite
mettre en place un système de salaire
universel un seul heure universelle
comme solution arroser tous moi c'est
super c'est génial et bat pas du tout
c'est une très très très mauvaise idée
parce qu'alors quand vous faites ça vous
fait quelque chose de très simple à
réaliser à la tête de la société
le super puissant pdg de la grande
entreprise d'intelligence artificielle
et pas contre le gentil peuple vous lui
dites aller manger survie sur ton
salaire d'universel et on reviendra plus
tard on en parlera donc c'est une très
mauvaise idée c'est tellement une
mauvaise idée qu on se dit mais hop mais
de façon c'est pas possible l'état ne
laissera jamais ça arrive et il verra
intervenir
et là encore non et ça c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle mais c'est quand même
vrai parce que la raison
et aussi très simple je récitais
vladimir poutine bosch moins bien sûr
que je veux pas te mentir mais on va
cité lagunaire footing qui dit
l'intelligence artificielle celui qui la
contrôlera il contrôlera le monde
il a pas tord malheureusement il arrive
vraiment pas tort et donc ils vont
retenir ceci
l'état n'interviendra pas n'est pas
possible tout simplement une raison très
simple c'est que l'intelligence
artificielle
c'est logique nucléaires de notre époque
ogives nucléaires
rappelle moi le thème du délit de séjour
c'est vrai que c'est positive énergie on
n'est pas trop positive énergique
rappelons le quand même l'intelligence
artificielle saluzzi quan finalement moi
ça me dit quand même plus à pardies
syrie est ce que tu te crois
intelligente
donc si tu regardes l'intelligence
artificielle c'est quand même plus ça et
puis au final il y a deux types
d'intelligence artificielle
la première elle est très simple elle
édite faible est là juste pour but de
stimuler l'intelligence par exemple
gagné aux échecs la deuxième par contre
elle est dite forte et non capables
seulement de 6000 et l'intelligence mais
aussi d'avoir une réelle conscience de
soi mais qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir en
fait de ça c'est que l'intelligence
artificielle
elle cherche à copier et recréer le
fonctionnement de notre cerveau
et tout ça pour quoi pour investir nos
industries regarder les voitures
autonomes
regardez la reconnaissance faciale et
tout ça il faudra le comprendre dans
l'éducation de l'homme de demain il
faudra être en collaboration avec cette
logique et non pas en compétition
et pour ça il ya une solution et cette
solution
elle s'appelle les neurosciences vous en
avez entendu parler rue moi j'en ai
entendu parler
alors les neurosciences est très simple
c'est l'étude des 6 et d'études
scientifiques des systèmes nerveux
autant du point de vue moléculaire au
niveau des organes comme le cerveau
alors là tu nous parles de gueuroz six
ans mais ça va voir ça dans les bien
justement et comtois tout se joue avant
6 ans c'est ce que nous montre
l'éducation pourquoi c'est très simple
on va prendre un exemple très simple 40%
aujourd'hui 40% ça représente 300 mille
élèves
ils sortent du cm2 avec de grandes
lacunes garderont toute leur vie et ce à
chaque année et ça c'est un gros
problème
et pourquoi car en fait on se rend
compte que chaque année en fait des
millions d'étudiants entre 0 à 6 ans
vont créer des connexions neuronales
et ça ça s'appelle la plasticité
cérébrale nous en créons entre 700 à
1000 par seconde pour apprendre à parler
compter et communiquer avec résoudre
petite comparaison très simple
aujourd'hui comme vous pouvez le voir
ceci et des synapses et comme vous avez
dans cette vidéo le réseau aujourd'hui
internet mondial aux portes
cent mille millions de connexions par
contre le cerveau d'un adulte moyen
comporte le triple de ses connexions et
attachez vous bien le cerveau d'un
enfant en comporte dix fois plus un
million de milliards de connexions
synaptiques dans son cerveau et pourquoi
ça car il suffit simplement d'être en
connexion avec le monde pour créer un
foisonnement de connexions neuronales et
au final va faire le ménage
après il va notamment faire le tri et
garder les meilleurs seront renforcés et
affaiblir les autres ça l'élagage
synaptique et il faudra retenir quelque
chose c'est que le cerveau ne retient
pas des meilleures expériences mais des
expériences les plus fréquentes
notre responsabilité donc très grande
car ce sont nos choix et nos habitudes
qui vont dessiner l'avenir des futures
générations
j'ai vu pas mal de résultats sur ces
écoles qui utilisé des méthodes assez
unique et notamment grâce à cette femme
maria montessori qui est en fait une
médecin pédagogue italienne absolument
visionnaire vous en avez d'ailleurs
sûrement entendu parler et cette femme
elle est à l'éducation ce que einstein
et à la physique alors la nuit rien que
ça et oui rien que ça
parce que cette femme elle créée en 1907
en fait une méthode
or cette méthode s'appelle la méthode
montessori elle porte son nom vous en
avez sûrement entendu parler
j'étais pas inspirer énormément de
professeurs et d'enseignants qui eux
sont bien notre époque et notamment
céline alvarez alors seignal varèse
c'est une prof qui travaille dans une
école et cette prof elle va changer
quelque chose elle va dire moi dans ma
classe il n'y aura plus de talent bien
alignant
il n'y aura plus de professeurs qui
diable pour le tableau rien que pour lui
les étudiants qui ne peuvent pas parler
non à la casse des signes alvarez qui
est une classe à jeunes vivier en zone
d'éducation prioritaire
ce sont des ateliers vous allez des
ateliers où les enfants peuvent
participer quand ils le veulent avec qui
ils le veulent autant de fois qu'ils le
veulent avec qui ils le veulent
voyez où je veux en venir ça c'est une
nouvelle obligation ou est ce qu'on veut
en venir au final c'est que sedin
apparaissent et maria montessori nous
apprennent quelque chose c'est que le
processus d'apprentissage aujourd'hui si
décompose en quatre étapes
le premier est très simple il s'appelle
l'attention
le second l'engagement le troisième le
retour d'information immédiat et enfin
vous avez la consolidation
commençons avec le premier j'ai commencé
avec la tension alors l'attention qu'est
ce que c'est la tension
c'est un outil extrêmement puissant
qu'on utilise tous les jours de manière
extrêmement régulière il va nous
permettre en fait de sélectionner parmi
tous nos sens lequel est le plus
intéressant pour traiter notre
environnement
ça va être clairement l'objectif est à
plusieurs sens vous l'aurez compris
plusieurs zones de stockage plusieurs
zones pour mémoriser ce que l'on va voir
donc quand vous allez écouter puis voir
quelque chose vous allez le mémoriser
dans différents endroits de votre
cerveau et j'avoue permettre de mieux
retenir et de mieux le ressortir plus
tard
quoi de mieux qu'une petite expérience
au final pour voir ça avait besoin
d'être attentif pour apprendre donc nous
allons passer un extrait audio qui est
en anglais donc il faudra être attentif
essaie de deviner qu est ce que la
personne dit soyez attentifs et
maintenant écouter alors on est d'accord
on va leur passer quand même essayer
d'écouter toujours rien on est d'accord
elle c'est clair maintenant si je vous
donne justement la vue et vous allez
voir qu'est ce qui est écrit c'est à
dire afrique brick city hunter hybride
qui veut dire je pense que le bric site
est une très mauvaise idée
et écoutez maintenant maintenant on va
revenir sur les deux premières vous
commencez à la voir on est d'accord on
va la passer
l'expérience est toute simple elle vous
a montré que les deux premières fois
vous n'avez rien compris pour la plupart
d'entre vous et au final si on vous
donne la bulle le texte et louis vous
allez comprendre parce que vous avez
activé plusieurs sens et c'est ça
l'apprentissage
alors une fois plus quelque chose a
suscité votre attention il va peut-être
pouvoir mériter votre engagement
on est à l'étape supérieure nous sommes
2.2 ou le reste suit alors un enfant il
va être beaucoup plus facilement attirés
vers un jouet qui va faire du bruit de
la musique que de la lumière tout savoir
ça ça me paraît évident et c'est tout à
fait vrai aussi pour nous adultes tous
les jours au quotidien alors qu'est ce
que c'est qu'en fait l'engagement
l'engagement ça va être une analyse de
plus poussée de votre environnement vous
êtes en fait à l'étape suivante vous
allez essayer de comprendre à des plus
de précisions alors il ya un facteur qui
est extrêmement important à ce moment là
c'est la difficulté ou la simplicité de
la tâche et d'approfondissement que vous
allez faire alors ils vendent très
simple ainsi quelque chose et beaucoup
trop difficile vous allez vous en
décourage à être souvent et si quelque
chose est beaucoup trop simple vous
allez vous-en désintéressé qui arrive
aussi vous comprenez bien que l'
équilibre entre facilité et difficulté
doit être parfaitement adapté à chaque
individu c'est un élément clé regardez
un engagement sur le long terme
donc la question que tout le monde se
pose c'est finalement comment engager
élèves et il ya une solution pour ça et
cette solution elle s'appelle le project
based learning et cette solution elle
est très simple elle explique notamment
que vous devez repenser les cours comme
des projets replacer tous ses cours dans
des projets personnalisés et qui
passionne vos élèves
on va prendre un exemple très simple
avec clément nous avons adoré un cours
un mook qui est un cours vous pouvez
prendre gratuitement en ligne qui était
comment créer sa propre version d'airbnb
en 48 heures et pourquoi nous avons
adoré ce coin pour une raison très
simple c'est parce que qu'importe les
prérequis nécessaires qu importe le
temps qu'il fallait
il répondait à un besoin personnel
et il faudra repenser les cours comme ça
c'est à dire qu'il faut mettre un projet
émettront réalité derrière ça on va
prendre un exemple tout simple entre
étudier le langage de programmation ruby
ne parle pas forcément ici à tout le
monde et créé airbnb jette-t-il
plateforme am mondialement connu le
choix sera vite fait et en plus
techniquement ça sera la même chose
alors tout à fait et ceci nous amène au
cou troisième point le retour
d'informations i média qu'est ce que
c'est ça facile lorsque vous allez faire
une action vous allez attendre un retour
de cette action alors il peut être
positif ou négatif ça c'est pas
l'important ce qui est important c'est
que ce retour d'information arrive le
plus tôt possible à ce moment là plus
vous êtes loin dans le passé par rapport
au temps d'information vous aurez de
l'intérêt est plus ce sera difficile de
corriger l'erreur alors cette correction
dès lors à l'art un but extrêmement
important qui centrale c'est le plaisir
le plaisir c'est la drogue de votre
cerveau c'est le summum pour faire
avancer votre cerveau et travailler au
final comment consolider tout ça et bien
il ya une solution qui est très simple
justement ces deux gars me fier grâce
comme ça s'inspire des jeux vidéo parce
qu'au final collectionner des notes ça
n'a jamais abouti des personnes par
contre montée des niveaux collectionner
des niveaux montée en compétence avoir
des projets beaucoup plus personnalisé
ça ça peut intéresser les élèves et au
final ça on le fait déjà très bien dans
de nombreuses organisations comme diane
academy et on arrive au quatrième point
notre dernier point de liste et on va
parler là de consolidation alors la
consolidation qu'est ce que c'est c'est
le fait de répéter
alors lorsque quelque chose va avoir
suscité votre attention qu'il va vous
avoir procuré du plaisir par un retour
d'information immédiat vous allez alors
très probablement vouloir répéter
l'opération pour avoir davantage de
plaisir
une boucle en fait très simple c'est une
boucle vertueuse et ces stimulations
multiples elles vous permettent à chaque
fois de réitérer l'opération
au final comment rect et pour ne pas
oublier une compétence
il ya une solution encore une fois elle
s'appelle le peer-to-peer learning
l'apprentissage entre étudiants c'est
très simple nous allons justement nous
échanger nos compétences il y à déjà de
grandes écoles
en france notamment une grande école
informatique française qu'on ne citera
pas le nom mais qui est le résultat de
six fois cette vidéo pour ceux qui sont
fâchés avec les maths c'est 44 - 2 abbas
pas gentil les profs là bas dans cette
école ils sont des coachs ils ne sont
pas du tout là pour vous enseigner
quelque chose ils sont là tout
simplement pour faire en sorte que les
élèves vont réussir leur tâche les
élèves sont en équipe donc il n'y a plus
du tout de lien subordination entre les
élèves
au final qu'est ce qu'il faudra retenir
de tout ça c'est que aujourd'hui le
processus d'apprentissage ces quatre
étapes la première c'est très simple
c'est l'attention
la seconde c'est l'engagement le
troisième le retour d'information
immédiat et enfin la consolidation et
qu'est ce qu'il faudra retenir c'est que
il faut désacraliser l'erreur l'erreur
est complètement partie prenante de
notre apprentissage et elle doit être le
socle de la construction de notre savoir
qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il faut réapprendre
il faut replacer le plaisir au coeur de
l'apprentissage il a alors il faut quand
même estimé que l'apprentissage quelque
chose de difficile
c'est un véritable challenge quotidien
on l'a tous vécu mais il faut bien
retenir qu'il n'ya jamais jamais de
mauvais d'étudiants il n'y a que de
mauvais système éducatif deux cerveaux
n'ont jamais et ne seront jamais il faut
bien le savoir
et aujourd'hui on continue d'enseigner
en rang sans bouger à des étudiants qui
ont des difficultés des facilités
différentes le même contenu sans tenir
compte de leurs forces et faiblesses
alors je vais utiliser une métaphore
pour pour bien vous image et cela
imaginez si un médecin prescrive et à
tous ses passions exactement le même
médicament peu importe leurs malades et
ce qui se passera ça serait tragique
vous l'aurez donc compris si les
pratiques pédagogiques évolué elles
doivent passer par les neurosciences
notamment être éclairée par les sciences
car les sciences rhône de
l'apprentissage va être actif et à forte
dimension collaborative et au final ne
faudra pas oublier l'éducation est un
enjeu majeur de notre société car
aujourd'hui les étudiants représentent
20 %
de notre population mais 100% de notre
futur merci
[Applaudissements]